we have seen a lot of advances in
physical machine learning and deep
learning so one thing that we have been
looking into is how we can leverage all
those new technology in machine learning
and deep learning and apply to deal with
the complexity in systems you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using if you're
like me you're no longer amazed by how
all your technologies can work for you
rather you've begun to take for granted
that they simply should work for you
instantly all together all the time the
fact that you're not amazed as a
testimony to the work that people like
dr. Lee dong zhuo assistant managing
director of Microsoft Research Asia do
every day he oversees some of the
cutting-edge systems and networking
research that goes on behind the scenes
to make sure you're not amazed when your
technologies work together seamlessly
but rather can continue to take it for
granted that they will today dr. Joe
talks about systems and networking
research in an era of unprecedented
systems complexity and what happens when
old assumptions don't apply to new
systems explains how projects like cloud
brain are taking aim at real-time
troubleshooting to address cloud scale
Network related problems like gray
failure and tells us why he believes now
is the most exciting time to be a
systems and networking researcher that
and much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Li dong zhuo welcome to the podcast
oh it's great to be here as the
assistant managing director of Microsoft
Research Asia you are among other things
responsible for overseeing research in
systems and networking and I know you've
done a lot of research in systems and
networking over the course of your
career as well so in broad strokes what
do you do and why do you do it what gets
you up in the morning yeah I think you
know this is one of the most exciting
times to do research in system
networking and we already have seen
advances of you know system and
networking have been pushing the
envelopes in many technologies we've
seen the internet the web web search big
data and all the way to the artificial
intelligence and cloud computing that
you know every cannot rely on these days
yeah all those advances have created
challenges of unprecedented complexity a
scale and in a lot of dynamism so my
understanding of systems is always you
know system is about bringing order to
chaos right the chaotic situation so we
are actually in a very chaotic situation
where things change so fast and a lot of
you know new technology coming and so
when we talk about system research is
really about transforming all those
unorganized pieces into a unified whole
right that's why you know we're very
excited about all those challenges and
also we realize over the years that it's
actually not just the typical system
expertise when talk about distribute
systems operating systems or networking
that's actually not enough to address
the challenges we're facing you have to
actually also master other fields like
you know database systems and
programming language compiler hardware
and also in artificial intelligence
machine learning and deep learning and
what I do it Microsoft Research Asia is
to put together a team with
diverse set of expertise and inspired a
team to take on those big challenges
together by you know working together
and you know that's a very exciting job
to have I love the order out of chaos
representation if you've ever been
involved in software code writing you
write this here and someone else is
writing that there and it has to work
together and then you've got ten other
people writing and we all just take for
granted on my end it's gonna work and if
it doesn't I curse my computer well I
had Shaolin Han on the podcast in
November for the 20th anniversary of the
lab there and he talked about the
mission to in essence both advanced the
theory and practice of computing in
general your own nearly 20 year career
has been about advancing the theory and
practice of distributed systems
particularly so talk about some of the
initiatives you've been part of and
technical contributions you've made to
distributed systems over the years
you've just come off the heels of
talking about the complexities now how
have you seen it evolve over those years
you know I think we are getting into the
year of distributions
being a distributed system person that
we always believed you know what we're
working on is the most important piece
you know I think Maxwell research is
really a great place to connect theory
and practice because we are constantly
exposed to very difficult technical
challenges from the product teams
they're tackling very difficult problems
and we also have the luxury of stepping
back and thinking deeply about the
problem we're facing and thinking about
what kind of new theory we want to
develop or new methodology we can
develop to address those problems I
remember you know in early 2000 when
Microsoft started doing web search and
we had a meeting with the debt manager
who was actually in charge of
architecting the web search system and
so had a you know very interesting
discussion and we talked about you know
how we were doing research in
distributed systems how we have deal
with you know a lot of problems when
server
fail so I have to make sure that the
whole service actually stay correct in
face of all kinds of problems that you
can see in a digital system I remember
at that time we had row 11 Leslie
Lamport you know a lot of colleagues and
we talked about protocols and at the
beginning the day manager base I said oh
yeah I know you know it's complicated to
deal with all these failures but it's
actually under control and a couple
months later he came back and said oh
you know there's so many corner cases
it's just beyond our capability of
reasoning about the correctness and we
need the protocol that we were talking
about it's also interesting that in
developing those protocols we tend to
make some assumptions say ok you know we
can tolerate a certain number of
failures and one question that general
manager asked was you know what happened
if we have more than that number of
failures in a system right and from
practical point of view you have to deal
with those kind of situations in theory
when you work on theory then you know
you can say ok let's make assumption and
that's just what under that assumption
so you see that there's a difference
between theory and practice the nice
thing about working at Maxwell research
is you can actually get exposed to those
real problems and keep you honest about
what assumptions are reasonable what
assumptions are not reasonable and then
you think about you know what is the
best way of solving those problems in a
more general sense rather than just
solving a particular problem your work
in networked computer systems is
somewhat analogous to another passion of
yours that I'm going to call networked
human systems in other words your desire
to build community among systems
researchers how are you going about that
I'm particularly interested in your
asia-pacific systems workshop and the
results you've seen come out of that so
I moved to Microsoft Research Asia in
late 2008 and when I was in United
States clearly there is a very strong
system community and over the years we
also see that community sort of
expanding into Europe so the European
system communities were started
distant workshop and eventually it
evolved into a conference called euro
sis and very successfully and you know
we see a lot of people getting into
systems and networking because of the
community because of the influence of
those conferences and the workshop has
been very successful in gathering
momentum in the region and so in 2010
remember it was chanted Sakura and Rama
kata who were my colleagues at Microsoft
Research and they basically had this
idea that maybe we should start
something also in asia-pacific region at
that time I was already working in
Beijing and I thought you know this also
part of my obligation so in 2010 we
started the first Asia Pacific system
workshop and it was a humble beginning
we had probably about 30 submissions and
accepted probably a dozen it was a good
workshop but it was a very humble
beginning as I said but what happened
after that was really beyond our
expectation it's like you know we just
planted the seed and the community
should have picked it up and grow with
it and you know it's very satisfying to
see that we're actually going to have
the tenth workshop are you how enjoying
August if you look at the organising
committee they are really you know all
would cross research from all over the
world it's not just from particular
region but you know really all the
experts across the world contributed to
the success of this workshop over the
last in almost 10 years now and the
impact that this workshop has is
actually pretty tremendous what would
you attribute it to I think it's really
first of all this is the natural trend
right you go from US was leading in
system research and then expanded to
Europe and it's just a natural
trajectory to expand further to
asia-pacific given you know a lot of you
know technological advances are
happening in Asia
and the other reason is because the
community really come together there are
a lot of Compton researchers that
originally just like me came from Asia
Pacific region so we had a lot of
incentives and commitment to give back
and all those enthusiasm passion or the
willingness to help young researchers in
the region and those that should
contribute to the success of the
workshop in my view well you were
recently involved in hosting another
interesting workshop or conference the
symposium on operating systems
principles right sauce sauce and this
was in Shanghai in 2017 it's the premier
conference for computer systems
technology and as I understand it's
about as hard to win the bid for as the
Olympics
it's almost why was it important to host
this conference for you and how do you
think it will help broaden the reach of
the system's community worldwide so
salsa is one of the most important
system conference and traditionally it
has been held in US and later on they
started rotating into Europe and it was
really a very interesting journey that
we went through along with Professor
hypo Chen was from Shanghai Jiaotong
University we started pitching for
having SSP in the asia-pacific region in
2011 it was like six years before we
actually succeeded we pitched three
times and overall even for the first
time the committee was very supportive
in many ways so that we'd be very
careful to make sure that the first one
is going to be a success and in 2017
when hypo and I open the converse I was
actually very happy that I didn't have
to be there to make another pitch I was
essentially opening the conference and
it was very successful in the sense that
we had a record number of attendees over
800 people
and we had almost the same number if not
a little bit more from the US and Europe
and we had you know many more people
from the region which was what we
intended and having conference in
asia-pacific is actually very
significant to the region we're seeing
more and more high quality work and
papers in those top conferences from
asia-pacific region you know from Korea
India China and many other countries and
I like to believe that what we have done
sort of helped a little bit in those
regards let's talk about the broader
topic of education for a minute this is
really really important for the system's
talent pipeline around the world and
perhaps the biggest challenge is
expanding and improving university level
education for this talent pipeline MSR a
has been hosting a systems education
workshop for the past three years the
fourth is coming up this summer and none
other than Turing Award winner John
Hopcroft has praised it as a step toward
improving education and cultivating
world-class talent and he also said a
fifth of the world's talent is in the
asia-pacific region so we better get
over there tell us about this ongoing
workshop
yeah actually John really inspired us to
get this started I think more than three
years ago and I think we're seeing a
need to improve you know system
education but more importantly I think
for MSI Asia one of the things that
we're very proud of doing is connecting
educators and researchers from all over
the world especially connecting people
from you know us in Europe with those in
Asia Pacific region and the other thing
that we're also very proud of doing is
cultivating the next generation of
computer scientists and certainly as you
said you know the most important thing
is education and during the process what
we found
is that there are a lot of professors
who share the same passion and we're
talking about you know a couple of
professors Lorenzo a VC from Cornell and
Robert Wayne RESA from Cornell and Jeff
Walker from UCSD they actually came all
the way from us just to be at the
workshop talking to all the system
professors from all over the country in
China and so I attended those workshops
myself the first one was five days and
the next two were like three days it's a
huge time commitment yeah but you see
all the passion from those professors
they're really into improving teaching
they try to figure out you know how to
make students more engaged how'd it get
them excited about systems even how to
design experiments all those aspects I'm
you know very optimistic that with those
passionate professors we're going to see
a very strong new generation of system
researchers and this is you know I think
the kind of impact we really want to see
from a perspective of you know Maxwell
research Asia it's not just about making
the lab successful but if we can make
impact in the community in terms of
talents in terms of the quality of
education that's much more satisfying
before we get into specific work I'd
like you to talk about what you'd
referred to as a fundamental shift in
the way we need to design systems and by
we I mean you in the era of cloud
computing and AI you've suggested that
things have changed enough that the
older methodologies and principles
aren't valid anymore so unpack that for
us what's changed and what needs to
happen to build next gen systems yeah
that's a great question I continue with
the story about building for torrent
systems so in the last 30 years you have
been working on system reliability and
we have developed a lot of techniques or
other protocols and we think it we solve
all the problems but if you look at how
this thread of work started it really
started in the late 70s when we were
looking
the reliability airplanes and so on of
course you know there are assumptions we
make about the kind of failures in those
kind of systems and we sort of
generalize those protocols so that I can
be applicable up until now but if you
look at the cloud it's much more
complicated in many dimensions and the
system also evolves very quickly and a
lot of assumptions will make actually
start to break and even though we have
applied all this well-known techniques
that's just not enough so that's one
aspect the other aspect is it used to be
that you know the system we build we can
sort of understand how it works right
and now the complexity has already gone
beyond our own understanding you know we
can't reason about how the system
behaves on the other hand we have seen a
lot of advances in for example machine
learning and deep learning so one thing
that we have been looking into is how we
can leverage all those new technology in
machine learning and deep learning and
apply to deal with the complexity in
systems and that's in another very
fascinating area that we're looking into
as well well let's get specific now
another super interesting area of
research deals with exceptions and
failures in the cloud scale era and how
you're dealing with what you call GRA
failure and you've also called it the
grace LAN which I want you to explain or
the Achilles heel of cloud scale systems
so how did you handle exceptions and
failures in a somewhat less complex pre
cloud era and what new methodologies are
you trying to implement now right so as
I mentioned you know today's we are
targeting those systems with assumptions
about failures like crash failure you
know the component can fail when it
fails it crashes I stops working and
nowadays we realize you know this kind
of sumption no longer holds so this is
why we define a new type of failures
called grave failures so thinking about
what kind of name to give to this very
interesting new line of research that
we're starting so we called it gray Swan
people already know about Black Swan or
great Rhino so firstly because we're
talking about the cloud we want
something not as heavy as writer one
something that can fly and the reason we
called ray is because you know assistant
component is no longer just black or
white it could be in a weird state where
from some dollar servers it's actually
behaving correctly but from the others
it's actually not and that turns out to
be behind many of the issues that major
problems that we're seeing in a cloud
and it has sort of some components of
black swan in the sense that some of the
assumptions will be making breaks so
that's why everything we build on top of
that assumption start to break down so
for example I mentioned the assumption
about the failure if you think that it's
either crash or it's correct then it's a
very simple kind of world right but if
it's not the case then all the protocols
that will work under that assumption
will cease to work it also has this
connection with grey rhino because Koree
rhino is this problem that everybody
sort of sees coming and it's a very
major problem but people tend to ignore
it for the wrong reason and in our case
we know that for the cloud all those
service disruptions happen all the time
and there are actually failures all over
the places it's just very hard to figure
out which ones are important but we know
something big is going to happen at some
point right so we try to use this notion
grace want to describe this new line of
thinking where you know we really think
about failures that are not just crash
failures or not even you know the
Byzantine failures where it's
essentially arbitrary failures but
there's something in between that we
should reason about and then using those
to reason about the correctness of the
whole servers so does the word
catastrophic enter into this at all or
is it yes that could be catastrophic
eventually how does that
kind of thinking play into what you're
doing if you look at the cow system it's
like a rhino sort of charging towards
you and before it hits you there a lot
of bests you know noise and other things
but it just don't know when and how
something bad is going to happen right
and could be catastrophic
it happens actually a couple of times
already and so one of the things we try
to do is to try to figure out when and
how bad things could happen to prevent
catastrophic failures from all the
deaths then maybe you know other signals
we have in a system there are signals
it's just we don't know how to leverage
them part of your approach to coping
with grave failures is a line of
research you call cloud brain right and
it's all about automatic troubleshooting
for the cloud it's actually a huge issue
because of the remarkable complexity of
the systems so tell us how cloud brain
and what you call deep view is actually
helping operators the people that have
to deal with it on the ground simplify
how they write troubleshooting
algorithms mm-hmm
so I think crop brain is well the
efforts that we have to deal with grave
failures and remember you know we talked
about the challenges that come from
complexity of the system or the scale of
the system it would really have you know
huge number of components interacting
with each other but on the other hand we
can really leverage the scale of the
system to help us in terms of your
diagnosis and all detecting problems
even figure out where the problem is
and this is the premise of the cloud
brain project so it has actually three
components the three ideas the first one
is really the notion of near real-time
monitoring and so instead of trying to
look at the logs and after the fact and
then analyze what happened we try to
have a pulse on what the system is doing
how it's doing and so on so that's the
first component and the second component
is we really want to form a global view
so it's not just one observation we make
about a system but
observations for all over the systems
combined so we can actually understand
how system is behaving and which part is
actually having problem and then the
third part is once we have you know all
this global observations that come in
real time then we can use statistical
methods to really reason about you know
what's abnormal and so on so this is
where we really leverage the scale the
huge amount of data and I used to be a
challenge and now becomes opportunity
for us to actually come up with new
solutions to handle the complexity of
the system so how does that help an
operator simplify writing an algorithm
right so now the operator actually has
all the data in new real-time and you
know you can write this very simple
algorithm that operate on the data sort
of like a sequel query right and then
you can emit signals and you know tell
people that something is wrong or
something is correct or maybe we have to
pay attention to a part of the system
that seemed to have some problems so
where is this great failure research
with all its pieces and parts in the
pipeline for production overall we are
not at the stage where we solve other
problems but we have pieces of the
technology we developed to solve some
specific problems like deep view and
cloud bring our you know two projects
that have already been incorporated in
Azure to deal with network related
problems for example but you know we're
far from solving that problem it's
really sort of a research agenda that we
set out probably for years to come
and one idea that we have been working
on which is actually very interesting is
that we really have to change how we
view programs in the past for defensive
programming we have been trained to
handle exceptions and it turns out that
handling exceptions in a large complex
system is not enough so one of the ideas
that we've been thinking about is
changing exception handling into
exception or error reporting so you
start to collect
all those signals that we talked about
you know the dust when the Rhino comes
charging at you so you have to really
collect those tests towards one place so
that you can actually reason about the
behavior of the system and that's you
know one of those major shift that you
know we see coming even in how we
develop systems not just you know after
the fact we already have this beast and
now we need to understand what's going
on
so those methodology I think is where
we're pushing you know it's not just
solving specific problem we have an
incident we try to solve this problem
yet we can do that but more importantly
and this goes back to the theory of
needs practice
so we need to come out of looking at the
specific instances but think about you
know what methodology we should adopt to
change the status completely so how do
you implement then a brand new thing I
mean we talk about the beast that
already exists and is growing what are
you proposing with your research right
so this is always a hard problem we
already have something running and it
has to keep running and now it has all
the problems you need to solve so one of
the ways we deal with those challenges
is trying to solve the current problems
you know like crowd brain and deep view
I sort of try to fit in to the current
practice but for some other projects
what we do is like you know what I
talked about changing from exception
handling to error reporting that
actually is a system we build that we
can transform automatically a piece of
code that does air handling in the
traditional way into a piece of code
that actually does our reporting in the
way that we desire right and that helps
because we don't want everybody to
rewrite the whole code base it's just
not possible
so we have to find ways to help
developers to sort of do the
transformation and also live with the
current boundary of the system and we
hopefully gradually we move towards the
right direction I think you see that in
just about every place software exists
is theirs
legacy system you've got a retrofit some
stuff that added complexity to it that's
right but you can't just make everyone
throw out what they're already using so
this is a big challenge I'm glad you're
on the job well we talked about what
gets you up in the morning and all the
work you're doing to make sure that
everything goes right that is basically
what you're doing is trying to make
everything go right right but as we know
as you know more than I know something
always goes wrong so given what you see
in your work every day is there anything
that keeps you up at night yes I think
we're realizing that the kind of
distribute system we're designing or
building are becoming more and more
important they're becoming part of the
sort of critical infrastructure of our
society and that puts a lot of burden on
us to make sure that whatever we're
building can be mission-critical right
and you know we have a lot of
researchers working on formal methods
verification just make sure that the
core of the system can be verifiable
we'll give some assurance that it's
actually working correctly and you know
we talked about applying machinery and
deep learning mechanism but it's
statistical so sometimes it's actually
naturally there are cases where it
breaks so how we can safeguard this kind
of system from what you call
catastrophic issues and this is also
another thing that we have been putting
a lot of sauce into and we're not short
of challenges especially on making the
cloud infrastructure really you know
mission-critical
Lee Dong tell us your story how did you
end up at Microsoft Research and how did
you develop your path to the positions
you hold right now
and looking back I remember when I
finished my PhD I start job hunting and
I got you know a couple of offers and I
talked to my advisor of course that's
what you do when you graduate student
and he basically gave me a very simple
piece of device
he said well just go where you can find
the best colleagues the colleagues with
maybe you know tutoring what caliber so
I end up going to Maxwell research lab
where at that time we didn't have Turing
Award winner but within ten years we had
two so that was how things started
looking back what's really important is
the quality of colleagues you have
especially an early stage of my career I
learned how to do research in substance
it's not about getting papers published
its internal passion that drives
research and I think the first phase of
my career is more on personal
development I remember being pushed by
my manager if I'm wrong Evan to get out
of my comfort zone we started as a sort
of technical contributor but then I was
pushed to lead a project and there are
always new challenges that you face and
you get a lot of support from your
colleagues to get to the next stage and
that's very satisfying and then I went
to MSR Asia where later become a manager
of a research group and I think that's
sort of the second phase of my career
where it's not about my personal career
development it's also about building a
team and how you can contribute to other
people's success and that turns out to
be even more satisfying to see the
impact you can have on other people's
career and their success and also during
that period of time I also realized that
it's not just about your own team you
can be the best system research team in
asia-pacific but it's more satisfying if
you can contribute to the community and
we talked about
starting the workshop and getting the
conference into asia-pacific and in a
lot of other things that we do to
contribute to society including you know
the talent fostering and many other
things and those in my mind are becoming
even more critical as we move on in our
career yeah so I view this as the three
stage of my career started with personal
development learning you know what it
means to love what you do and do what
you love and then think about how you
can contribute to other people's success
and increase your ability to influence
others and impact others and positively
and finally in what you can contribute
to the society to the community and
being very fortunate to have been
working with a lot of great you know
leaders and colleagues and I've learned
a lot on the way and I remember in a
work with a lot of product teams as well
and they also offered a lot of career
device and support so this is just you
know my story I guess you know it sounds
to me like almost a metaphor you know
you start with yourself you grow and
mature outwards to others and then the
broader community impact that ultimately
a mature person wants to see happen
right I hope so I get the sense that it
is it's just about seeking the truth
it's not about you know getting papers
published it's not about you know
tracing Fame or you know all those
things that we start to lose sight of
you know what the true meaning of
research is it's not about all this
resultant that we try to get but truly
it's about finding the truth and
enjoying the process along the way at
the end of each podcast I asked my guest
to give some parting advice to our
listeners what big unsolved problems do
you see on the horizon for researchers
who may just be getting their feet wet
with systems and networking research
well I think they are very fortunate to
be a young researcher in system
networking now I remember I was talking
to but labs and when I started my career
in 2003 and he said you know he was
feeling lucky that he was doing all the
work in the late 70s and early 80s
because it was the right time to see a
paradigm shift and I think now we are at
the point that we're going to see
another major paradigm shift just like
you know folks in zero spark what they
did was essentially to define the
computing for the next 30 years even now
we're solute living in the world that
they defined looking at the PC even with
a phone I mean that's just different
form factor right they sort of defined
the mouse the laser printer all the
things that we know about and the user
interface and the reason that happened
at that time was because the computing
was becoming you know more powerful from
super computers to personal computing
because you know we can pack so much
computation power into a small machine
and now I think you know the computation
power has reached another milestone
where computing capability is going to
be everywhere and we're going to have
intelligence everywhere around us the
boundary between sort of the virtual
worlds and computers and our physical
world will disappear and that will lead
to really paradigm shifting
opportunities where we figure out in
what computing really means in the next
10 years or 20 years and this is what I
would encourage everyone to focus on
rather than just incremental improvement
to the protocols and so on because we
are really seeing a lot of assumptions
being invalidated I would really have to
look at the world in a very different
view and from you know how we interact
is sort of the computing capability and
how we expose computing capability to do
what we need to do and it's not just
doing computing in front of a computer
but not doing everything with sort of
the computing capability around us and
that's just exciting to imagine and I
can't even describe what the future will
look like but it's up to our young
researchers to really make it a reality
Li dong zhuo it's been an absolute
pleasure thanks for joining us in the
booth today Thank You Gretchen really
pressure to learn more about dr. V dong
zhuo and how researchers are working to
bring order out of systems and
networking chaos visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]